foreign
[Music]
thank you
and that
and then we we go we can uh we've seen
the Ariane five
lift off roaring through the Tropical
Sky carrying juice well there we are
we've seen uh liftoff so uh David white
towels it has gone ahead uh so far so
good it was aborted yesterday that was
down to the weather wasn't it but we
have seen there uh how it has gone ahead
at 1 14 and this is Europe as we can see
on screen there Europe's first dedicated
mission to Jupiter and uh we heard some
words there the countdown was in French
and that was because it has taken off
from uh French Guiana that's right isn't
it how relevant is that to these
missions well French uh the French were
the main force behind Ariana's bus and
this has been launched on an Arion 5
rocket and it's best if you can to get a
launch site near the earth's equator
because you get the additional impetus
to the rocket of the Earth's spin when
you launched in an easterly Direction so
that's why this is coming from French
Guyana and uh it seems to be so far a
few minutes in a an excellent launch
it's going to be a busy couple of
minutes because at two minutes 16
seconds into the flight the main engine
um now the jet at the um the jet the
solid rocket boosters you see there has
come off from the side these provide
most of the thrust for the first few
minutes then less than a minute later
the fairing which encloses the payload
the juice satellite comes away and then
a few minutes after that the the main
thrust of the rocket Falls away and the
second stage starts so there are over
the next 32 minutes several important
points that have to work perfectly in
order to get this this satellite in the
right position now as you saw it
disappeared into the clouds there so
there's no more visual sightings in the
next uh visual sighting they will get
will be from an onboard camera after all
these events have happened 32 minutes
after the launch so this is this is the
most critical part of the whole mission
we saw earlier this year a rocket
launched from underneath the jumbo jet
from Cornwall which failed just a few
minutes uh before it was due to go into
bit so there's always a tense time but
from what I can see on the other screen
here this is going according to plan at
the moment well that's highly
encouraging isn't it Dr Whitehouse thank
you for now let's talk to our Science
and Technology editor Tom Clark and as
Dr Whitehouse was saying Tom it's always
a very nervy isn't it the first few
minutes of any launch
absolutely I'm here in the uh the lobby
of Imperial College in London it's a big
crowd that had a sort of launch party
here because Imperial had one of the
instruments on the juice Mission so
there's a lot riding on this for them
but of course the European space
actually there was a big chair when the
rocket took off and as I can see I'm
looking past you at the screen behind me
everything seems to be proceeding
exactly according to plan the fairings
just separated uh that first stage is
making its way into uh to orbit this is
not the first though critical moment
there are several others to come up it
has to acquire a ground signal from a
station in Australia then a really
crucial moment for juice and for the
success of its Mission it's a fast solar
panels have to begin to unfold way out
600 million miles from Earth where
Jupiter is sunlight levels are very very
low it needs huge solar panels in order
to do any of its scientific operations
so unfurling this big array of panels is
another crucial step not going to happen
for another couple of hours so I'd love
to
indeed Tom's so far so good fingers
crossed it has launched it didn't
yesterday did it because of the weather
but there it has uh lifted off and we
will follow it's a trajectory trajectory
as much as we can